Joe Biden has been only been in the race
for one week and he's having his
presence felt across America
it's like he's hugging the nation and
breathing on our necks yep a survey by
total jobs found that three out of four
people want all physical contact banned
at work coincidence I say no it's now
just too hard to figure out exactly what
is appropriate and now some companies
actually want to ban handshakes all in
an effort to curb the creeps and our
corridors so no more physical contact
altogether abdicating our roles as
sensible humans leaving it all up to the
people at HR who can annoy you without
even touching you which I'm totally 100%
behind just like Joe well make that 99
percent the pros banning all touching
including handshakes means no one will
ever be able to say you made them feel
uncomfortable and that's good if someone
in management wants to fire you not
touching anyone also reduces the spread
of viruses especially when ed Henry's
around now the cons we can no longer
tell who the weirdo is if the weirdo
can't be weird in public and that's how
I choose my friends I avoid the guy who
likes to shake your hand and refuses to
let go while he talks it's like a mutt
who won't give up a ball I also avoid
that lady who caresses my back while
showing me a cat cartoon from The New
Yorker ha ha it's not the caress but the
cartoon that really bugs me now how do I
know who's weird if they're banned from
being weird maybe it'll get a show on
CNN that's usually a big hint wrote that
whole thing just so I could slam CNN
alright Jesse you shake a lot of hands
don't you I do or do you fist bump you
see look at this bumper I do both first
of all Greg like how are you supposed to
seal a deal yes shake hands shake deals
I mean that's what happens in business
all the time you also spot weirdos by
how they dress so usually how I spot
them it's bearable what's a tail on that
out if they dress anything like Greg big
shoes you know these are a band okay
well that's that's in the weird category
and you have your jeans rolled up oh my
god forbid maybe you know what your
highest one wife is so good wad that we
have to focus on handshakes well you
know what I happen to disagree with 75%
who said
they think we should ban all of it yeah
because to me it's like a cultural norm
in the United States you shake hands you
meet somebody come on hello I mean the
reality is in Europe they kiss each
other on the cheek I know I mean that's
anybody that's just normal but my sister
likes to do two three on how many times
I kiss in Japan they bow to each other
bring Obama back into that just for the
heck of it
Dana you would like me I sense that you
like your own personal space I'm a
hugger oh you really you never hugged me
you know that's a biological problem
Dana I can't control it obviously I got
to work but the robots will be here soon
enough
yes we don't need to try to beat them to
it yeah oh good goods are meant to when
you get a soft handshake it creeps you
out Jedediah there's a presidential
candidate I know in the race that has a
weak handshake it's not a woman well I
was gonna say what's happening to this
world you know there's crazy crap going
on everywhere and we're focusing on a
handshake well I'm a germaphobe so the
idea of a handshake really that's ironic
is you Barry okay see I don't get this
now the Germans are here I'm like a
Howard Stern style German how he
like won't touch anymore what was the
other guy Michael Jackson Harvey Mandel
I like calling him Harvey Mandel
invasive because you know I saw her hand
sanitizer a lot and I am a hugger but
for a select group yes people in the
subway I hope people on the subway
usually by surprise